I když kvantové počítače nebudou vhodné k řešení
všech problémů, existuje několik tříd problémů
a potenciálních použití, kde očekáváme,
že kvantové počítání bude mít vliv.
Patří mezi ně simulace,
jako je modelování procesů a systémů, které se vyskytují
v přírodě, prohledávání a optimalizace —
hledání nejlepšího nebo
optimálního řešení v situaci s
mnoha možnými odpověďmi — a matematika
a zpracování dat se složitou strukturou,
včetně aplikací pro strojové učení.
Kvantové algoritmy přistupují k těmhle druhům problémů
novým způsobem a využívají
jedinečné vlastnosti kvantové fyziky, jako je
superpozice, interference a provázanost.
Běžné počítače uvíznou
při prozkoumávání určitých oblastí výpočetního prostoru,
takže tyhle vzory nedokážou najít.
Kvantové počítače jsou vybaveny
extra schopnostmi nebo vyšším výkonem
u některých problémů, které jim dává jejich kvantová povaha.
Abychom plně pochopili potenciál kvantových počítačů,
je potřeba se ponořit do teorie výpočetní složitosti —
odvětví informatiky, které se soustředí na
měření a porovnávání výpočetního úsilí potřebného
k řešení různých druhů problémů.
To poskytuje užitečný rámec
pro popis různých urychlení
a tříd problémů, se kterými se setkáváme ve
výpočetnictví.